- I could feel the juice oozing
out the sides of my face.
(festive piano music)
- Every guy has his own paan guy.
- I know nothing about paan.
- My parents love this and
I'm only doing this video
so that they don't disown me.
- But yeah, I was forbidden
from ever having paan,
and I don't know why.
- Like the paan table is
usually the only table
in an Indian wedding
that is more crowded
than the buffet table.
(playful music)
- He's just got paan-cepted.
- You put chocolate on
anything and it tastes good.
- This is awesome.
- (speaks foreign language)
- It's like mint chocolate but leafy.
- There's a smooth, sinewy of chocolate.
- This isn't as horrible
as I expected it to be.
- I feel like really full already.
(playful music)
- There's one leaf is
greener than the other,
so I'm assuming this will be better.
- We're relaxed.
- It's light, it's coconutty.
- No weird explosion nonsense
bullshit going inside.
- I actually ate the whole
thing, like I enjoyed it.
- You can't even swallow you have to keep chewing.
- Well I can taste a lot of gulkand,
that's a rose petal paste.
- Why can't they just
get rid of these leaves
and have the rest of it.
(playful music continues)
- This is the paan I
used to get my grandmother.
(speaks foreign language)
- Mmm, it's not bad.
Now I know why it's the
most popular one in India.
- For a moment there, I let maybe--
- This is like ass, and that's
the most professional way
I can describe it.
- It's just like more and
more slime in my mouth.
- My whole mouth has become really dry
after having this.
- Why am I eating paan that I do not like?
- Has a really bittter aftertaste.
- Yea, really bitter, but it's kinda nice.
(playful music)
- This is the paan with the tobacco and--
- The one you spit out.
- This tastes great.
- God this is strong.
- [Voiceover] Did you swallow it?
(laughter)
- It's gone now.
- And like the taste, I don't
think I'm gonna get this taste
out of my mouth for a while.
- [Black t-shirt man] Oh my God!
(spitting sounds)
- It may be the most famous,
but sorry, it's the worst.
- God you ate most of it.
- Let us bring attention to
our fingers for a moment.
This is what we have done.
- This kinda made me miss my
dad and all the paan outings.
- It has to be an acquired taste.
- The paan was a little chewy,
but I'm definitely not having paan solo.
(laughter)